so women so you're talking about I'm
saying that you know the man at a
certain level can't do certain things if
you were with Joe schmoe and he wasn't
treating you the way you believe Joe
schmoe should treat you then why you
would leave like do women women have the
gatekeeping so if you get Joe Schmo and
he treats you like you're you're his
Queen treats you perfect good if you get
a [__] guy at the absolute upper
echelons of value and and you still
don't aren't happy with what he's giving
you then leave women are The Gatekeepers
you women actually have all of the Power
this is what's beautiful to about the
whole thing women are constantly
complaining you have all the power
you're the ones who get to choose do you
know who you should be mad at for all
this [__] I'll tell you you should be
mad at you know who threw away all the
female power in the sexual Marketplace
promiscuous females because now you got
chicks who bang anybody without trying
so why should a dude get up and try no
you